49 years old and I've got about
$220,000 in student loans and I've been
paying for about 19 years what's your
household income Brian I make about
$90,000 a year the program is cut your
lifestyle and pay this off in 12 months
that's the program live on 70,000 and
pay this off in one year that's about
$1,800 a month and that means you're not
going out to eat and it means you're not
going on vacation and it means you're
not doing half the other crap you've
been doing with your
$90,000 and you're going to finally
address this head on that's the program
quit looking for a shortcut man it's not
work for you you're going to have to hit
it right straight in the nose hit the
bully in the nose